for you edgar with the narco corrido
movement
is it more about respect than just sort
of guns and
and drugs and you know the money in
women is it more about
rising up and people gaining
affluence through this whole yeah i
think it's it's it's about respect
everywhere you go not only in that i i
think uh
if you respect the next man he'll
respect you back and
um and sometimes
people i guess they want to feel good by
listening to this type of music or any
type of music anything that makes you
feel good you want to listen to it right
and and in my type of business
you can actually call me up and if you
want and you know
i'll write a song about you and
and and and i and i go back on that
if there's a certain line that you gotta
you know put yourself and just don't
cross that
and don't disrespect anybody and you'll
be good
well i read one of the comments on
youtube and it was in spanish and i put
it in google translate and it said
there are countless ways to change the
world but the way these individuals
behave
it's like a volcano about to erupt what
are your thoughts
um what what individual us
the the whole narco there are ways to
to change and to rise up but is this the
right way to do it
it's been erupting since 1910 because
that's like the farthest corridor that i
know
so i guess it's it's a non-anti-volcano
no it's uh i don't um
how can i say this it's just uh
it's just what's in it's it's it's it's
something popular i guess it is
if um if it's a volcano today tomorrow's
gonna be an avalanche but it doesn't
matter something's always gonna happen
well there's a great scene in the film
where you're on a farm and i think you
commented
how peaceful and calm it was do you ever
long for that life
yeah that's why i say sometimes i would
love to go and live in mexico
i would love to go and i i
i don't know there's been plenty of
times when i sometimes i tell myself
maybe in another life
you were out in in in some in some ranch
with cows and because sometimes i feel
like even though i'm born and raised in
los
angeles california i feel like i'm i can
i can um relate more to people from the
ranch
than people from the city and i guess it
yeah it just it does make it makes me
feel a little
more peaceful one out on mexico does